[Musica]
Qual è la prima cosa che fate quando
vedete una cosa bella
pensate di essere per la prima volta di
fronte allo Skyline di New York
di guardare per la prima volta la
nascita di Venere di Botticelli agli
Uffizi di osservare per la prima volta
le rovine di Machu Picchu in Perù
Qual è la prima cosa che fareste
Pensateci un attimo
Beh la cosa più logica sarebbe guardare
davvero quello che sia di fronte per
goderne della Bellezza
darsi del tempo per osservare i colori
le prospettive le luci le ombre i
contrasti Ma cos'è che facciamo spesso
prendiamo uno smartphone e scattiamo una
foto
o una foto che rimarrà nel dimenticatoio
della libreria del nostro cellulare
una foto anonima che potremmo trovare
identica facendo una banale ricerca su
Google
una foto che condivideremo sui social
solo per mostrare noi stessi in vetrina
agli altri
ma abbiamo davvero guardato quello che
avevamo di fronte
ne abbiamo davvero assaporato la
bellezza
Che cos'è la bellezza
da una delle sue definizioni è la
qualità capace di appagare l'animo
attraverso i sensi divenendo oggetto di
meritata e degna contemplazione
non si può dunque parlare di bellezza se
non si parla di animo e di sensi e del
tempo dedicato alla sua contemplazione
Amo viaggiare e quando sono in viaggio e
percorro le strade di città sconosciute
mi dedico alla fotografia al cosiddetto
Street Portrait o ritratto di strada
il ritratto di strada è molto diverso
dalla fotografia di strada o Street
photography questa infatti è una
fotografia rapida una fotografia che
immortala la vita di strada nel suo
essere frenetica le auto che sfrecciano
per le strade e le persone che
attraversano gli incroci In tutta fretta
il ritratto di strada invece
è una fotografia lenta
è una fotografia in cui ci si deve dare
del tempo
creare un legame empatico con la persona
che sia di fronte
chiedere il permesso di scattare la foto
scambiare due chiacchiere sorridere
Essere cordiali
guardarsi negli occhi
darsi del tempo per creare una
connessione emotiva con il soggetto
solo così solo creando una connessione
emotiva è possibile davvero guardarsi
negli occhi e assaporare La vera
bellezza delle cose
la fotografia nasce nell'Ottocento e nel
corso dei decenni ha subito dei drastici
cambiamenti
impostato c'era la fotografia analogica
Che prevedeva l'utilizzo dei rullini e
quel che accadeva che la fotografia
veniva sviluppata nella cosiddetta
camera oscura ovvero una stanza oscurata
illuminata esclusivamente da una luce in
attinica rossa
attraverso un ingranditore avveniva
l'esposizione della carta fotografica la
quale Poi andava incontro allo sviluppo
attraverso le fasi della riduzione del
resto e fissaggio
negli ultimi decenni invece Con
l'avvento della fotografia digitale lo
scatto avviene attraverso un sensore
digitale il quale immagazzina tutte le
informazioni visive in formato grezzo
anche detto Raw il quale poi viene
rielaborato in quella che potremmo
definire Camera Chiara ovvero un
software digitale in cui al computer
riusciamo a pulire l'immagine grezza e
renderla più bella esteticamente
ottimizziamo quindi l'esposizione il
bilancio dei bianchi le luci le ombre I
Chiari gli scuri rendiamo quindi
l'immagine più bella senza renderla
diversa dalla realtà che abbiamo
fotografato
Non creiamo quindi qualcosa di di falso
e di non veritiero ma ottimizziamo la
qualità dell'immagine per renderla più
bella
e ci sono professioni in cui la bellezza
è qualcosa di intrinseco al lavoro
stesso Se pensate a pittura e scultura è
facile associarle alla bellezza ma è
possibile applicare la bellezza dei
campi molto lontani da essa e è
possibile applicarla per esempio alla
medicina in particolar modo la
cardiologia
nei pazienti con malattia della valvola
mitrale la terapia è spesso la
riparazione chirurgica e il chirurgo
Infatti un po' come se fosse un sarto
ripara la valvola con degli interventi
sempre meno invasivi evitando di
sostituire la valvola con una protesi
che può essere molto più problematica
per la vita di un paziente
nella pianificazione dell'intervento
chirurgico un ruolo fondamentale e
giocato dall'ecocardiogramma
transesofageo una sorta di gastroscopia
per intenderci in cui una sonda
ecografica viene inserita in esofago e
il cuore viene visto più da vicino
andando ad acquisire delle immagini 2D e
3D della valvola mitralica
l'ecografo quindi acquisisce delle
immagini che in fotografia a definiremmo
grezze
un po' come abbiamo visto per la camera
Chiara in fotografia è possibile
rielaborare queste immagini con dei
software dedicati per pulirle e renderle
più belle esteticamente
ottimizziamo quindi il guadagno tagliamo
i piani anatomici ruotiamo l'immagine
andiamo ad utilizzare l'effetto
fotorealistico la transilluminazione per
ottimizzare le luci e le ombre rendiamo
quindi le immagini della valvola
mitralica più belle
l'ottimizzazione estetica delle immagini
ecografiche della valvola mitralica non
è fine a se stessa ma rende i meccanismi
della patologia mitralica più chiari ed
evidenti
ci permette di capire cioè Dove e con
che meccanismi la valvola è malata Se
c'è un prolasso Se c'è una rottura di
corde tendine le caratteristiche
dell'anello
e questo è molto importante perché ci
permette di capire dove e con che
meccanismi la valvola è malata e ci
permette di dire al chirurgo dove
intervenire Come poter riparare quella
valvola senza sostituirla con una
protesi
miglioriamo quindi la qualità
dell'immagine ecografica per migliorare
la cura dei pazienti con insufficienza
mitralica
la bellezza come mezzo per avere più
cura del paziente
concludendo è possibile applicare la
bellezza dei campi molto lontani da essa
come per esempio la cardiologia
così per esempio un insegnante se
utilizza la bellezza e un po' di
passione può trasmettere i propri
studenti non solo le frasi scritte sui
testi scolastici ma può entrare nella
storia può mettere le mani nella chimica
può declamare la letteratura
così un avvocato per esempio si utilizza
la dialettica può convincere affascinare
della propria tesi difensiva se davvero
crede in essa
così per esempio un architetto un
ingegnere possono ottimizzare il
rendering del progetto di un ponte di un
edificio per convincere della solidità
del progetto
Quindi per un attimo
pensate al vostro lavoro
a quello che fate tutti i giorni
e così come la bellezza può essere il
mezzo per avere più cura del paziente
pensate a come la bellezza e l'estetica
possono rendere Quello che fate più
interessante
datevi del tempo e metteteci passione
qualcosa di bello nascerà
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]